ah that's gum resumes Peter back today
we're gonna play the scariest game of
all time you know it's a good game when
this is your loading screen all right
this is a swab simulator I could click a
run away and all right great great idea
this game came out three months ago and
it was funny three months ago but hey
we're gonna play today anyway okay I'm
going to play the single layer shrek is
oh god damn it
God didn't say that I'm pretty sure
unless God is an onion oh yeah I did all
right let's just play this this is
actually kind of spooky I'm not gonna
lie
if I was alone in a forest like this
knowing there was a Shrek on the other
side I would probably clench my butt
cheeks very very hard what is this oh
god oh god what is that Merrill what are
you doing calm down bear Oh calm down
all right I found the other one I found
the other this is the best this is the
greatest slender copy of all time oh
yeah that house is totally on fire I
better get in there Xin lei there's an
onion there donkey yeah oh my god I'm so
scared right now oh Jesus Christ
Oh how is that
that's official it's the greatest
blender coffee of all time I saw an
onion here somewhere
oh shut up I have a strange urge of this
[ __ ] huggin him very immersive
experiences never felt so scared of
Shrek my whole life I'm never gonna be
able to listen that to that song again
without thinking about Shrek nice little
puddle of water here very realistic
oh there he is seriously
I said pooper I'd better be an onion in
there that is an onion in there
fantastic
oh god it's getting really scary now
I've never been too scared in my life
I wish I had the heartbeat sensor on
right now because it's beating like a
bongo drum feel free to write all your
Shrek puns in the in the comments
section oh you already did
oh that's great thank you so much oh my
god it came out of nowhere
[Music]
I know it's our love song but not in
front of the press I'm gonna get
copyrighted Shrek just shut up for one
second thank you
Oh God Jesus Christ I thought they
didn't exist finally oh my god oh god
there is yeah I got it so fast
god dammit I bet he had sex with sanic I
don't think that makes a pass a go up
the last one must be up here right damn
it it's gonna be a rock star
god dammit he's so [ __ ] fast
Wow
oh god he's so fat son of a [ __ ] I'm
still that makes you scared what [ __ ]
Jessica I don't want it I get it
[Music]
I think I'm the only one to ever get
scared playing this [ __ ] game Jesus
Christ oh [ __ ] yeah I don't want to play
it anymore I'm sorry that's that doll
that's all folks oh I don't look like a
mean door watching hit this guy come to
earth today and I'll see going yeah yeah
I got a trick buzzer really they're so
funny brofist